[Music]
my next guest appeared on scrubs now she
plays Shelley the daycare teacher on
raising hope here's a clip of her in
action take a look rusty
sometimes things can make you sad
sometimes things can make you mad you
might be feeling mangy or your diapers
might be changing or your diaper might
need changing I don't know but whatever
it is it's got you grumpy a thorn in
your paw or a great big dumb P you need
to stay calm and follow my golden don't
fight you know I've wanted to talk to
you for a while and I'm so glad that
you're here and I sort of wanted to find
out about you first of all like if for
example you you consider yourself a
country girl is that right which I
didn't I didn't know that it was true
but yeah kinda I mean I grew up in what
I thought was the country because I was
born in New Jersey but then when I was 8
we moved to Pennsylvania
oh yeah New Jersey's not the country
[Applause]
yeah I hope that you moved to
Pennsylvania yeah to Nazareth
Pennsylvania where there really isn't
much happening oh you're from Nazareth
all right but no there's like a lot of
fields and I thought oh I'm gonna be a
country girl I was eight I made my mom
buy me a corncob pipe and I would like
walk around the yard like hey I'm Huck
Finn you know but nobody has a corn
no one smoked a corncob pipe in like 200
years no oddly they sold them at the
bagel Smith in New Jersey so we bought
them and then moved offensively did you
ever do any country stuff did you go
hunting yeah my dad hunts yeah he's
killed a lot of things
but but mostly one day he killed two
deer a girl deer and a boy deer on the
same day Wow
I know I felt really bad for both of
them but I wrote a letter to the deer in
Pennsylvania to stay away from my dad or
he will kill them it's it's called deer
deer what bothered you about the boy and
the girl on the same day maybe we're on
a date you know and then now they were
hanging up at our house they're together
now you were playing the ukelele was
that the first instrument that you
picked up have you always been musical
well I've always played instruments I
played the piano since I was four and
then when I was nine they the band
director came to school and they let you
pick an instrument and he played like
you know all the different instruments
and then the trombone you played the
trombone and I was like oh man
everybody's gonna pick the trombone and
that's like clearly the coolest one but
it was only me and this kid Ryan that
picked Rimbaud and everybody else picked
like saxophone or drums or something
like yeah I I i played Trumbo I even
played in the marching band but I wasn't
very good so I would just kind of like
move my slide like pretending you know
it's an easy instrument to fake it don't
even have to really know it yeah you
don't have to
you're having a bad day you're just like
whatever you know
just move your arm around sure now you
do a speaking music you do a monthly
musical show tell us what is will tell
us about this show what's it called well
it's up a Steve Allen theater and it's
called playing with Micucci you made
your name of course Micucci you weren't
trying to to be you know oh that's the
dirtiest part of the whole show I mean
like there's cookies and puppets it's
really clean for the title but but I
didn't know what coochie meant for so
long like I always like 25 years old
reading The Vagina Monologues and I was
like what
wait so you this is your last name and
you didn't know no and then so all the
times the kids had made fun of me I had
no idea what they were talking about it
was like I had this flash like like all
the times kids made fun of me like like
if we have a kid we should like name
Phil
or Sharon okay
season 1 of raising Hope is available on
DVD now and you can see plan with
Micucci April 14 Peppa Steve Appling
Theatre in Los Angeles Kate Micucci
fantastic thank you
[Applause]